c
mike antoine pas footballeur c'est
bastos qui bouge que nature gauche
parlait qu'astrid
les producteurs n'ont contacté mon fait
lire un scénario américain n'avait pas
été tourné aux états unis et qui m'ont
demandé s'ils veulent adapter et le
réaliser je dis donc qui se lève pour
aller aux toilettes juste une fois
qu'elle a tourné à droite pendant la
toilette rentrée de
antoine est georges tempez la tête
urgent de lever un truc au fil de toutes
façons elle sera déçue je trouvais là
les ingrédients que j'aime bien les
codes ville étaient respectées et en
même temps une espèce d'originalité
liberté possible dans le traitement de
base puisque ça se passe sur deux
époques différentes mais il ya des
flashbacks
vous n'êtes pas un peu vite là on
cherchait un mec trentenaire ken belle
gueule qui est séducteur qui peut
représenter un danger pour l'apprendre
julie le personnage et en même temps qui
a une autodérision kia qu'il ya
quelqu'un de plus sentimental que ce
qu'il n'y paraît dans tout ça je je
l'imaginé volontiers chez nicolas bedos
est jalouse des mythes folle teillage je
veux comme tu expliqué ludivine on s'est
rencontré et là c'est pareil sinon
rencontre je réalise que j'ai devant moi
à la fois une actrice exceptionnelle
vraiment très très doux et très
professionnelle et en même temps une
fille beaucoup plus simple que ce que
j'imaginais fin simple au sens
accessibles comme une copine comme la
girl next door est mignonne qu'il nous
fait un peu fantasmé public était à côté
de moi julie mais genre yassia côté
poids juste à côté mais antoine parce
que je sais je sens que tu t'emmerdes on
a tous envie
du coup de foudre du les disputes du
quiproquo des moments où on se manque
d'un rien pour des détails on enrage
parce que c'était bon et puis en fait
l'hôte a cru que c'était pas bon voilà
c'est ça date depuis des lustres
c'est vraiment la vie vous retrouvé
miraculeusement la femme de votre vie
et puis jusqu'à sa gueule
à cela on passe à des cas revient que
subiront une grosse paire